Brandon is with us in Sacramento hey
Brandon welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hello how are you better than I deserve
what's up so about five years ago I was
in a bike accident and the medic had me
airlifted out later my health insurance
tells me that it wasn't necessary and
ended me with $20,000 for the airlift
and my question is do I pay it well the
problem you've got is this the airlift
did not have a contract with the medical
insurance you did okay okay so you are
on the hook for $20,000 period right you
have a deal with them they lifted you
out you have to pay them the only
question we got is whether you could sue
your health insurance company and get
$20,000 out of them oh because they're
the ones that are letting you down the
airlift people did nothing wrong they
just did what the medic told them to do
come get you and save your life
right right and so you know you walk
into a hospital you know bleeding and
they sew you up and then your health
insurance decides not to cover it
your deal is not with your health I mean
your deal is with the hospital they
sewed you up you owe them for sewing you
up you know service provided bill do
that kind of thing but then the health
insurance doesn't pay it then you've got
a problem with your health insurance
company and that's what you've got here
and so you're gonna pay this is what
you're gonna do because they're gonna
sue you and get it from you otherwise
okay
now what is your household income I
think I'm on route for a 30 K okay
and so $20,000 is not laying around
everywhere no okay
now if you have a $20,000 bill that you
can't pay that's five years old they
will negotiate with you to settle the
bill
and so what I would begin to do is begin
to talk to them and say what will you
take as settlement in full remember that
phrase settlement in full and my guess
is they'll probably take four or five
grand and then you get an extra job
delivering pizzas and you scrape up four
or five grand and you give it to them as
one lump sum settlement in full you get
in writing from them that agreement
before you give them any money while all
that's going on I'm going to contact an
attorney about suing this health
insurance company because I think they
didn't have a claim here that might not
be that they might you might be able to
get out of their hide and if I can get
it out of their hide it doesn't cost me
anything right yeah and so I'm gonna you
know take all of my in my health
insurance paperwork to an attorney and
sit down and go guys is there is do I
have a case here I mean can can you
force these guys to pay this bill and if
they say no you not got a chance then do
what I'm talking about deliver pizzas
and offer them three or four or five
thousand dollars to settle this and get
it out of your life but it might be that
you know maybe they're just playing
games with you then they think they can
get away with it the problem is this is
getting really old
meaning you said five years ago yeah and
you haven't dealt with it up until now
so here's the thing between now and
Christmas you need to get busy I've been
doing yeah you don't have to get up all
up in everybody's grill here and so go
ahead and call the health insurance
company back say I'm going to see an
attorney my financial coach says you
ripped me off and if you guys don't
reconsider this claim I'll file an
appeal what do I need to do you've got
to pay this claim I make thirty thousand
dollars a year a Medicare lifted me out
because I was broken in half and by god
you guys are going to pay this and start
messing with the health insurance
company get on the phone find an
attorney go sit down with them take them
let them mess with the health insurance
company meantime get extra job and start
building up cash meantime tell the
people at the airlift place you ain't
got any money you make $30,000 a year
good luck you can't collect anything
today I'll be back to you either with
the health insurance currently paying
you or with me making you a settlement
offer sometime after the first of the
year
and then you take Christmas to start
piling up cash working three jobs and
everything else and get ready to settle
this in case the attorney says you don't
have a case
you're gonna lose don't bother and sue
them it's a waste of time and then
you're just gonna settle this debt and
you got messed over and I'm sorry hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]